what i would like to do in this video is
to see if we can prove
that triangle
d
c a
is congruent to triangle b
a c
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out on your own
all right now let's work through this
together
so let's see what we can figure out we
see that segment dc is parallel to
segment a b that's what these little
arrows tell us and so you can view
this
segment ac as something of a transversal
across those parallel lines and we know
that alternate interior angles would be
congruent so we know for example that
the measure of this angle is the same as
the measure of this angle or those
angles are congruent
we also know that both of these
triangles both triangle d c a and
triangle b
a c they share this side which by
reflexivity is going to be congruent to
itself
so in both triangles we have an angle
and a side that is that are congruent
but can we figure out anything else
well you might be tempted to make a
similar argument thinking that this is
parallel to that because it looks
parallel but you can't make that
assumption just based on how it looks if
you did know that then you would be able
to make some other assumptions about
some other angles here and maybe prove
congruency but it turns out given the
information that we have we can't just
assume that because something looks
parallel that or because something looks
congruent that they are and so based on
just the information given we actually
can't prove congruency
now let me ask you a slightly different
question
let's say
that we did give you a little bit more
information let's say we told you that
the measure of this angle right over
here is 31 degrees and the measure of
this angle right over here is 31 degrees
can you now prove that triangle dca is
congruent to triangle bac
so let's see what we can deduce now well
we know that ac is in both triangles so
it's going to be congruent to itself and
let me write that down we know that
segment ac
is congruent to
segment ac it sits in both
triangles and this is by reflexivity
which is a fancy way of saying that
something is going to be congruent to
itself
now we also see that a b is parallel to
dc just like before and ac can be viewed
as part of a transversal so we can
deduce that angle c a b
let me write this down actually doing a
different color we can deduce that angle
c
a b c
a b
is congruent to angle a c d
angle
a
c d
because they are alternate
alternate interior
interior
angles
where a transversal intersects two
parallel lines so just to be clear
this angle
which is cab is congruent to this angle
which is acd
and so now
we have
two angles and a side two angles and a
side that are congruent
so we can now deduce by angle angle side
postulate that the triangles are indeed
congruent so we now know
that triangle
d
c a is indeed congruent to triangle
b
a c
because of
angle angle
side congruency which we've talked about
in previous videos and just to be clear
sometimes people like the two column
proofs i can make this look a little bit
more like a two column proof
by saying these are my statements
statement
and this is my
rationale
right over here and we're done